foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
in less than 18 months china's dramatic
crackdown on descent in hong kong has
forced dozens of the city's civil
society groups to disband
effectively bringing the pro-democracy
movement to a dead end
more than 150 people have been arrested
under the national security law
introduced by beijing in 2020
a criminalized subversion succession
colluding with foreign forces and
terrorist activities
several core members of the league of
social democrats have been jailed for
illegal assembly are in custody facing
national security trials including
chang's husband county founder learn
quote home
[Music]
the party is known for its socialist
politics and confrontational style in
the legislative chamber
and is active in street protests
thank
out
the hong kong security bureau says the
arrests and prosecutions are based on
evidence strangely according to the law
and have nothing to do with an
individual's political stance
the next challenge for activists is the
legislative council election
beijing introduced a patriots only
election system which makes it nearly
impossible for the opposition to stand
in the legislative council election
i'm sure that now that we have a
legislative council comprising patriots
administering hong kong
all these
endeavors to work more closely
with
the mainland authorities to
render
ourselves
contributing to the national development
will get more support the security
bureau also aims to reintroduce article
23
a long shelf national security law that
will criminalize espionage and text of
state secrets
all right
charm things activists should strive to
keep the civil society movement alive
with
foreign
china is not giving up her fights for
democracy but the future for activists
like her is unclear
foreign
[Music]
you